Hello, everyone. My name is Dave Kehr.
I am a curator here in the Department of Film
at The Museum of Modern Art.
You may have seen me in some of the
"How To See" videos.
"The tidal wave! It's coming!"
Talking about the economy of B-movies,
the survival of Westerns into the 21st century,
or how to preserve silent films.
You've sent us a lot of good questions on
those videos
so we thought it was time to do a Live Q&A
on MoMA's YouTube channel
and get you some answers.
You might ask questions like:
"What does a film curator do all day?"
Bill Frankeberger wrote:
"Wow. Can someone restore the Méliès films?"
Actually our friends in the Cinémathèque Française are working on that right now.
The Superhero/Comic genre.
"Do you agree with someone like Spielberg who says it'll eventually go the way of the Western?"
So please leave some questions for us in the comments section below.
And make sure to tune in on Wednesday, July 25
at 3:00 p.m. New York time
and we'll answer those questions and other questions that you submit during the live-stream.
In the meantime, please have a look at some
of the other videos we've made here at the Museum.
You can see some here.
And here.
And be sure to subscribe to MoMA's YouTube
channel, so we can send you a notification
when we go live on Wednesday, July 25.
Thanks, and see you then.